welcome to another thankful thursday i
believe it's important to thank the
people in your life in your business
who've had an impact who've helped you
because you cannot do this alone you
need other people's help and it's nice
just to say thank you and show some
gratitude and appreciation now and then
to those people who've had an impact on
your life
so today i want to thank richard
yagutilav and rich
used to be in my mastermind group that's
how i met him and now he's part of my
movement program he is on a powerful
mission to inspire people and wants
people to live their best life possible
and he tries to inspire them through his
pictures and through his his videos i've
collaborated with rich on a couple of
projects the first one was i think at
least was uh
my headshot and if you look at my
profile picture in a lot of my social
media it's a black and white kind of
serious headshot and i remember seeing
this picture of steve jobs where he had
a black and white headshot with you know
lighting on one side and i thought
that's a really cool picture i wanted to
do something similar and i showed it to
rich and said we could totally do that
and he came over one day and he snapped
it up and
boom i had a profile picture it was
amazing from there he came when he
interviewed me
and uh asked me some great questions
some that caught me off guard and so
some fun responses
and then we made a believe by you gotta
love video and i said rich i'd love to
let your art shine let me promote one of
your videos make a video about believe
something that would fit well on the
channel whatever believe means to you
make a video about it and i'll promote
it on my channel and right now it's
closing on 150 000 views so huge success
so far still growing the goal is to get
it to a million plus
a lot of great comments on it people are
really impacted by it it's touched a lot
of people and now we're working on
another
secret video project that uh i can't
release details of too much yet because
it's confidential but coming soon to a
screen near you
it's great when you can work with
artists and people around you who who
love what you do who support your cause
who are on their own path and rich is a
really talented
artist and photographer and and
filmmaker who is going to
change the lives of millions of people i
feel that and i know that and and i'm
excited to be able to
be able to look back and say i knew rich
when he was just getting started i knew
richard he was at the bottom and was
building his way up so rich thank you so
much for all your great help all your
support all the the the love you put
into your art and and for
your desire to
to help me and also to help have a
strong impact on this world
it means a lot to me and so for those of
you watching take two minutes today to
thank somebody who's had an impact on
your life write them a note make them a
video send them an email go visit them
and surprise them with a donut or a
coffee something just something to say
thank you because again you can't do
this alone you need the people around
you to help you out and saying thank you
and showing some gratitude is a great
way to make you feel better them feel
better and to help your business grow
believe
for those of you watching like the video
you want to see more just like this you
can subscribe to the channel to see more
thank you so much i'll see you soon
every week i share my best information
to help you fuel your business forward
in my newsletter check it out below
hi i'm jason j ross fonseca of
riseonline.com and i want to say evan
carmichael's newsletter is consistent
fun inspiring and it's the only
newsletter i prioritize and look forward
to period